men should not cry in public it is  unmanly and dishonorable rare exceptions  can be made to this rule but we make far  too many exceptions and the exceptions  are pretty obvious a loved one dies your  child is born your bride is walking down  the aisle at your wedding in the latter  two cases a dignified tear or two may be  acceptable but please don't turn the  faucet on okay there's no reason to go  overboard don't try to prove a point  other exceptions Can Be Imagined we've  talked about some of them before perhaps  for example you're saying goodbye to  your family before embarking on a  three-year Voyage to Mars maybe you're  watching the end of the movie Rudy aside  from those rare occurrences the point is  that men should comport themselves with  a certain level of stoicism and dignity  learning to control their emotions and  projecting an image of strength of  someone who is composed and in control